Youngevity Ultimate
Destress. A comprehensive stress support
formula. A blend of essential vitamins,
minerals, and botanicals that support
adrenal
[Music]
health. B vitamin complex for nervous
system health. B1, B2, B6, B12, and
penttothenic acid.
Magnesium and valyan root extract to
support muscle relaxation and promote a
sense of
calmness. Nutrientrich adrenal
substance. It supports those with low
adrenal levels and helps maintain energy
levels and
[Music]
focus. Easy to take capsules formulated
with high quality ingredients.
Manufactured by Youngevity, a leading
name in highquality health and wellness
supplements. Ultimate D-stress.
[Music]